welcome back to CBS this morning CBS
News has just confirmed that President
Trump wanted Attorney General William
Bar to publicly declare that no laws
were broken in mr. Trump's July 25th
call with Ukraine's president The
Washington Post reports Bar refused to
speak out about that phone call which is
at the heart of this impeachment inquiry
on Twitter last night the president
called the story totally untrue
meanwhile House Democrats are getting
ready for public hearings in the
impeachment inquiry starting on
Wednesday bill Taylor the top US
diplomat in Ukraine will testify at the
first hearing he's one of at least five
officials to say the president did block
military aid to Ukraine while asking
that country to investigate Democrats
including Joe Biden sources tell CBS
News the White House is hiring former
Florida Attorney General and Trump Ally
Pam Bondi and former Treasury spokesman
Tony saying they will help the president
with his messaging in the effort to
fight off impeachment the impeachment
proceedings on Capitol Hill could
eventually pull some senators running
for president from the campaign trail
and that includes Kamala Harris her
national poll numbers are falling and
she closed all three of her field
offices in New Hampshire recently CBS
News special correspondent Alex Wagner
interviewed the California Senator for
the Showtime series the circus she
discussed her strategy if impeachment
reaches the Senate you're gonna have to
say silently as a juror have you thought
about the sort of psychology of that
yeah I've thought about my own sitcom
well it's gonna be I've never been able
to sit on my hands and so you know we'll
see there is a lot of this that is that
has precedent and then some of it that
does not but in the meantime you're just
gonna practice some self-discipline I'm
gonna really try
and Alex Wagner joins us now Alex good
morning good morning guys it's good to
see you in person so it's difficult to
imagine Kamala Harris staying silent as
a juror I know I mean it is a
fundamental question there are six
Democrats who are senators who are also
running for president Kamala Harris is a
former prosecutor she had said I am the
person that knows how these impeachment
proceedings should run and yet her role
when it goes to the Senate is going to
be to sit quietly as a juror and not say
any time een you see what she's saying
look I thought about this it's gonna be
hard for me to sit on my hands to say
nothing of the fact that all these
Democrats want to be in Iowa at
precisely the moment that an impeachment
trial is going to be unfolding you know
well she just shook up her campaign
staff laid off some people and shifted a
lot of resources to Iowa what does that
say about where she is look the campaign
is very clear if they don't do well in
Iowa they have problems so they're going
all in and then the hope is there is
some momentum some lift from a strong
finish probably not first or second but
maybe third or fourth and they can use
that momentum through South Carolina
which is really where the Harris
campaign thinks they will do well they
have effectively I believe they will not
say this publicly dismissed whatever is
going to happen New Hampshire because
Bernie Sanders and Elizabeth Warren or
from neighboring states and they think
the south will be good for this campaign
the question is whether they have the
resources to get there so the
impeachment query hearings open to the
public next week starting on Wednesday
what's the significance of that since I
think so many people feel I've already
heard everything well I think that
there's something but there there's a
difference between reading about
closed-door depositions and seeing them
on your television and hearing life and
hearing people say the words I did this
the president told me to do this that is
meaningful Republicans have been
pressing for you know open door hearings
they're getting what they wanted there
is going to inevitably be a lot of
grandstanding Republicans feel like they
are under pressure from the White House
to mount a more strident and public
defense this will be their opportunity
to do that and Democrats no doubt feel
like the more information that the
American public is presented with the
more their case is open engine meanwhile
the Republican defense of the President
is shall we say evolving yes what
is the euphemism what is their strategy
here it's threefold at present one you
have a group of Republicans saying
there's nothing to see here there was no
quid pro quo this is a non-issue two is
you know what Lindsey Graham has taken
this tact the White House didn't really
have a strategy that was articulated
there was no quid pro quo because they
weren't organized enough for it and then
the third piece is there was a quid pro
quo but it doesn't rise in the level of
an impeachable offense they have not
found ground to stand on in terms of a
unified strategy these public hearings
are gonna be tricky though aren't they
for moderate Democrats and and moderate
Republicans yeah if you look at the
polling that came out earlier this week
support for impeachment is underwater in
key battleground states
that's Michigan Wisconsin Pennsylvania
Florida North Carolina Arizona that is a
problem for moderate Democrats who
effectively won in 2018 and handed the
speaker's gavel to Nancy Pelosi they
have got a jockey line where they are
performing their constitutional duty but
also do not appear to be overtly
partisan because voters back at home
I've talked to these voters they still
very much care about jobs health care
trade the environment impeachment is not
their list it is not the thing that is
animating kitchen table discussion yeah
and it's a reminder not to pay attention
these national polls on a peach exactly
the state polls really matter most the
deep dive Alex thank you very much
season four of the circus continues this
Sunday on Showtime which is a division
of CBS we're proud to say check your
local listings